chut with mini new so here's a question
that resonates with my I shall say
razor-sharp acumen why is the sky blue
that hasn't been answered since
childhood you know what here's the
problem I asked once and they were like
Maya business and that was we might say
I want to become an atmospheric
scientist it is my business
there you go that would have it a very
[Laughter]
spirit scientist so alright so if the
answer is easy to understand it's just
not simple first of all is the sky blue
yes okay well at least we got that it
doesn't look blue to you it's fine
that's what we're about to talk about
all right okay so here's a deal the
explanation is actually simple it just
takes a little while to explain okay
that's all alright alright I have time
alright so we have an atmosphere okay we
all know this yes we did it
it's composed primarily of nitrogen okay
a 78% nitrogen that's 20 21% oxygen and
a few percent other carbon dioxide this
sort of thing mixed in there are
particles of like pollen and dust and
sand from sandstorms and pollution and
smog and so particulates particulates
particulates okay now light comes from
the Sun mm-hmm
white light people people say the Sun is
yellow it's white right okay exactly
you've seen the Sun in the middle of the
day it's white it is why okay that's the
proper color of the Sun in the middle of
the day let's not get racism it don't
have to be the proper cup why is
everything Rachel into you
all right so you may remember that white
light is composed of colors right okay
put this light prism that's how you get
a rainbow right or your your educator
you said prison but through a raindrop
it spreads mounted to college and you
get the colors of the rainbow
Boise bib okay give them to me right red
green blue yellow Roy igb Roy red orange
green Roy yeah red orange yellow green
blue and ultraviolet but Valley bid okay
indigo violet thank you red red orange
yellow green blue indigo okay the seven
colors of the spectrum okay
if you come the way our brain works and
the sensors in your retina okay the rods
the cones the other rods give you shades
of light and intensity the cones a
disentangle color okay okay and you have
an RGB cones this week at RGB for I
heard that in computers and computer
screens and everything okay so you're
you're you are chemically with the
chemicals in your retina splitting that
red light into combinations of red green
and blue okay okay broad combinations of
these three if you have more red than
the others than what you look at it's
going to look more red to you if you
have more blue than the others gonna
look blue now here's what happens white
light comes down from the Sun the
particles in the atmosphere some of them
are about the same size as the
wavelength of blue light sweet all right
now if the if you have a particle and
light and there's a particle is the same
size that right it'll reflect that's
right it'll did or scatter that's the
proper word okay bounce scatter and so
that light doesn't make it straight
through its sins in every other
direction
oh so the light from the Sun is
selectively has the blue
moved on its way down to Earth's surface
and the and the blue scatters into the
air and you have a blue sky that's very
romantic is beautiful now
it's called Rayleigh scattering got him
Rayleigh greatly we get it re yl aigh
okay Lord Rayleigh you and Lord the Ray
alright so so here's the thing as the
Sun gets lower in the atmosphere right
the path length of the light is much
longer through the air okay so in other
words so here's your atmosphere if
you're directly above you're going
through it like this thickness and
should come down the thickness gets more
right okay right well more atmosphere
more scattering right the sky gets more
blue okay so in the daytime it's quote
sky blue that's actually a pale Braille
it's a very pale as you go to Twilight
that sucker gets deep yeah it gives deep
blue and so much more blue gets taken
out of the Sun I just love how violent
deep blue it's deep and if you take that
much blue the Sun I got no blue light
left at all so what color is it going to
turn kind of red kind of red gotta read
got a red amber yeah okay that's why
sunsets are red that's because so much
blue was taken out right that is that's
all it has left to give you is the side
of the spectrum we have red orange
yellow that's know sometimes you have a
very bright sunset that's not quite deep
red mark many particles therefore that
sunset all right many particles sweet so
that's so kind of a lighter cut like yes
so so the sky wouldn't get as intensely
blue when that happens it'll be similar
to the sky blue you had earlier in the
day so that's that's why we have a blue
sky nice now it's also why you can't see
stars in the daytime other than the Sun
well it's not it's not oh you can't see
stars they come because the Sun is out
that's not why because the Sun is
brighter than the star light that you
would otherwise see
no that's not why well see that's
intuitive knows how you with intuitive
but it's wrong
the reason why you can't see stars in
the daytime is because the scattered
blue light has rendered our atmosphere
aglow the answer is glowing blue light
and that prevents you from seeing the
Stars behind it if you took away the
atmosphere you'd be able to look up and
see the Sun will be there but then you
like dark adjust over here and there's
Fulton Scott full stars right over here
over there over there all around oh man
you know what what if we didn't need
atmosphere I'd want to get rid of it
okay so now this is what led to the
operational definition of the edge of
the atmosphere okay okay it's it's just
it's kind of operational it is how high
up in the air do you have to go before
there aren't so many air molecules above
you for the blue light to scatter and
prevent you from seeing the night sky so
it's really about the number of
particles it's not against an hour the
actual no it's just a density particle
wherever that happens so we agree just
by convention if you go up a hundred
kilometers okay converted to get 62
miles hundred kilometers that's about
where the atmosphere is thinned out so
there's no longer scattering blue light
it is no longer a glow and in broad
daylight you can see stars in the
nighttime sky so that's the operational
definition of space the operational
definition of space is 62 miles above
our ground surface kirai surface where
you can just see space basically because
that Mikayla's is still a mystery there
was not dense enough to scatter blue
light and render it a glow to prevent
you from seeing the night sky
now I'm not comfortable with that opera
I understand it okay I'm not comfortable
now what's your problem with that
because if the atmosphere were half is
thick as it is whether that would be
only be 30 31 31 miles that would be
space well suppose we're a tenth is it
then it would be three miles suppose we
didn't have an atmosphere
you'd be a space just standing here
sitting here like this
should that be called space that's I'm
saying it's our definition of space is
linked to how the circles
answers of our atmosphere that Cottam
except well no I see what you're saying
now because I was about to say it kind
of makes sense because you can't breathe
in space but you can also cannot breathe
at 35,000 feet
that's why yes where you can breathe
hard enough to breathe just on a
mountaintop exact you've won a quarter
mile on a mountaintop so now you said
what was your operational definition of
space be if it is not indeed this this
particular in atmospheric link I've
thank you take out the atmosphere either
you're in orbit or you're going
somewhere then you're in space so you're
using
oh god you are such a damn astro fatigue
as the measure of what makes space and
that would be true no matter what
atmosphere we had gravity fit into this
okay you talking about our atmosphere so
you know how much atmosphere that is 62
miles that's high up I'll show you all
right oh my god you had to break a globe
to show us look at this is this is this
is my god just hold this God holding
like the globe that's right okay so I'm
gonna show you here's the United States
right and I just did some distances I
know of New York to Boston yeah yeah
that's 200 and 200 miles okay I have 220
month no 180 miles okay all right so so
you take a third of that distance okay
that's 60 okay make that go vertically
up all right that's the edge of our
atmosphere 3/8 of an inch up 3/8 of one
inch off this is what makes it is is oh
my God we're in danger
so Earth's debt is not cold
Earth's atmosphere is to earth as the
skin of an apple is to an apple that's
what I'm saying 'we don't have much air
we are in danger that air is frail and
fragile oh my god you're doing what to
it and we're doing all kinds of nasty
stuff to it that is unbelievable
would you eat an apple that somebody
just rubbed crap all over no oh that's
insane
also I didn't I didn't sorry I misspoke
3/8 of an inch up
that's the altitude of the International
Space Station orbiting oh my god so our
atmosphere is actually yes so I'm just
looking to hear there's New York and
there's Boston so you're talking a
couple of millimeters but you know
millimeter above that's terrible that's
the thickness of the air above which we
say you entered space why are we not
teaching this in school I mean seriously
if you if if you ever want to have a
true appreciation of just what a
delicate balance we live in that is it
right there
correct ah correct it's chilling that's
really cute of an Apple is to an Apple
as the shellac on this globe is to the
globe itself oh that is our atmosphere
oh my god dude
well there you have it we're all gonna
die so that's why the sky is blue that's
right that's why we should look after
this little bit of air that we got here
on the surface of the earth I'm with you
and it's wide Neil thinks space should
be defined by gravity not probably the
circumstances of our hemisphere happen
to be there you go you know I'm gonna
agree with all three man yeah and not
because you're my boss Startalk info bit
as always people here
[Applause]
[Music]